what is life like now for you when you
see LA and you come to Montreal
what are you preferring better wine trio
is always at home that's where my family
is
yes my friends my co-workers also became
part of my my life my big part of my
life I consider them family so I
consider Montreal home right
but La La's been good to me too yeah yes
sure
what do you see yourself doing in LA
because here you were a teacher and you
were you know inspiring students and
fundraising and making a difference in
the community so what do you see your
life like in LA I still picture myself
teaching back in LA yeah and obviously
being with this foundation absolutely
yeah
do you plan to take that to the state
right now because I just the first time
I start up a foundation there's a lot of
nitty-gritty things I didn't know about
now I want to give back to the Montreal
community first right and extend it to
Canada but yes of course eventually I
would love to even to go worldwide and
especially commit the special needs
community worldwide but right now I'm
just concentrating on Canada sure can we
talk about the summer plans I are you
spending any time with Nick in the
summer yeah ok yeah because I had read
somewhere that you guys are spending
some time rumors do not we aren't redose
cowboy not and I don't I was talking
about that with someone this morning you
know it's easy for people to just come
up with a story right so we we avoid
that and just concentrate on our
relationships but no we're spending yeah
this is the first time I've been away
from him because I'm starting up the
fundraiser so I have a lot of things I
need to prepare back home in Montreal
because it's really hard to do that over
the phone and over over Skype and but
he's coming down you're going to be
spending a few weeks in Montreal here
he's coming back down for with me for
the fundraiser which on July 16 we're
going to be there yes on July 16 yeah
our den is sponsoring it's going to be a
Lux rentals showroom rate you'll see
it's going to be there I'm a huge fan I
think we all love DJ oh yeah so it's
going to be a big event Nick Nick and I
will be there and it's going to be a
workout event oh great yeah so you find
out you're like working out so you
can you tell sure i'll work out for you
no problem and the foundation i'll be
there i you were talking about the
negativity before and how you know your
students were telling you how do you
deal with it right so how do you deal
with the negativity because you have a
bunch of fans who obviously love you but
then there are the people who are like
oh it's not going to last I know it's
not real and it's fixed and all that and
I see that it's real because you're just
glowing you're beaming right so how do
you deal with those negative comments I
think it comes with the territory and
you're in the limelight there's going to
be people that are going to say positive
things and people that are going to say
negative things and sometimes in life
it's a lot easier to focus and hone in
on that one negative comment yeah but I
try to stay out of it I don't try to
read anything or read into anything and
it's been really great to he's been
great at like telling me how to just be
positive like what we found each other
yeah really that that's what matters
laughing you should be focusing sure you
guys found love now I know he's done
with reality shows especially The
Bachelor Yeah right he's done with it in
love with me exactly
he did fine alone with you and you found
love with him but are you guys done with
reality shows all together right now we
are I mean you never know what could
happen but we don't have any plans on
doing any reality TV right okay that's
good you guys want to work together
maybe I would love to huh yeah that
would be great what would you guys do I
have no idea okay we'll be plenty of
time is laugh about that okay any plans
for the wedding have you started
thinking about it or you're just
enjoying being engaged just enjoying
being engaged yeah yeah this is good
because you really haven't had time to
be a couple right and we've been so busy
he was on Dancing and I've been working
at my foundation so now that dancing is
over like now my foundation my
fundraiser has been taking a lot of my
time too
so we're just enjoying life together and
it's been so fun what have you learned
about him that you didn't know about him
on The Bachelor um well we didn't spend
like mornings with each other but I so I
remember the morning that we got engaged
he woke up and he was cooking me
practice Anais yeah he's a really great
cook and he cleans up after himself too
I didn't man oh good so should I do
those dishes
and he's a softy so he ran a soup
kitchen I think is a soup kitchen or and
we say he rent like a soup kitchen back
home for like years and he was part of a
church and I'm like why would you never
talk about this it's like my heart
melted when he was telling her stories
because he has such a he's a really good
guy and what did he learn about you that
he didn't know when you guys are on the
back when did he learn about but he was
like really you can do this I mean you
could say something like camera we're
not going to talk about that we can't
talk about that no not at all okay so
that's what can we talk about the
Rachael Lindsay yes do you still keep in
contact with her I'm closer to other
women okay that were in the house but
she's she's an amazing Bachelorette yeah
and I think they made it like a really
great decision with her I haven't seen
the first episode yet I haven't in my
homework yet right I heard there are
some really good men on her season and
I'm really happy for her she deserves it
charity enough that she's engaged I mean
everyone ends up engaged on the show
right so I don't think it's a surprise
you're right that's a good point but do
you think it was good for her to say
that she's in love and she's engaged and
I mean she looks so happy you should
probably couldn't hide it right but I'm
really happy for her now I'm following
both you and Nick on Instagram and you
guys are just pouring out the love and
showing everybody how much you love each
other was it hard to keep it a secret
all that time yeah yeah yeah especially
with like the one thing I have to say
that my friends and family back home in
Montreal were really supportive and were
they respected my privacy they weren't
asking me too many questions so at that
point I didn't feel like I had to hide
the secret because no one was really
asking me anything but you know whenever
I would fly down to visit him so like
where you going I'm like all you know
just gonna take another like Oh laughing
but yes it was nice to finally not feel
like we have to keep this major she
shouldn't be scared that we might they
might flip and come out yeah you know I
called it I said it Montreal is going to
win everybody knew that the Montreal are
widening we're a little bit